right a writer's review my new movie
Lincoln Lawyer in space mmm-hmm
interstellar so interstellar is the new
movie directed by Christopher Nolan's
the story of this movie is earth is
dying it's just it's shitty you look at
it you're like I don't want to live
there dust clouds everywhere they do a
good job at establishing the world
people need farmers people need food the
last source of food we have is corn and
soon that's gonna go away and people are
going to die and they need to find a
solution the solution is to go to
another galaxy through a wormhole
Matthew McConaughey he's gonna leave
that charge along with Anne Hathaway and
a robot who looks like was he look he
looks like Legos like when you would
take Legos and piece them together and
just walk them when they're not attached
he's no Michael Fassbender I'll say that
but he's a block and he's efficient he
does the job well now first of all what
was great in this movie Matthew
McConaughey was great in this movie for
sure
he leads the charge in this movie he
leads it well dudes a great actor I mean
you watch him work you're like I'm so
glad you had to come back and like I
said Lincoln large pays and sometimes in
a movie you need a little kid to be in
the movie and usually if that's the case
don't whatever gonna have a little kid
in the movie have a kid be a good actor
the girl who plays Murphy she's she's
good she's really good actually earned
McConaughey back and forth at a point I
was like I like you as a father daughter
do you really want him to succeed for
the same reason he wants to succeed he
wants to succeed for her and then you go
off into space exploration when you're
doing something like this you're gonna
have relativity the theory of relativity
and this movie shows that relativity
really well also it's really well
executed you really feel like it's like
oh oh no you're losing time and the
music the music was really creepy
this awesome intense organ music that
was playing when the scenes were getting
intense when you had to feel that
emotion and I felt it I'm not gonna lie
reviewing the movie like this is
difficult because whatever you liked or
didn't like in this movie you have to
explain but if you explain it you give
away plot points it might not be huge
plot points but the point of this movie
is that you don't really know a lot of
it going into it so you want to hold
that secrecy for you guys the audience
is just it's gonna be difficult but in
things being imperfect this movie's not
perfect talk about the pacing in this
movie because the thing that binds this
movie together keeps you engaged is the
whole bond between Murphy and Matthew
McConaughey if that
wasn't in there this would simply be a
space exploration movie about making pit
stops in another galaxy that's the movie
you have the visuals to keep it company
you're like oh that's red and there are
moments where you like oh that feels
like I'm actually in space which I love
that stuff that is awesome but
ultimately it's just you make a pit stop
here and you make a pit stop here and it
takes three hours to tell this story
about pit stops the movie didn't have
that flow it didn't feel like everything
was plotted out and everything was
really hashed out and Christopher Nolan
spent time making sure everything feeds
into right yeah that's great like at
parts McConaughey and his crew had to
improvise the situation to get out of
certain tight spots so you feel like
that improvisation that the characters
were doing Christopher Nolan was doing
as he was writing the script as he was
filming the movie if you like the last
act of this movie as much as it was
actually my favorite part of the movie
it was detached from the rest of the
movie you feel like when he was pitching
it to the studio he was like and then he
just drew this big convoluted thing on a
bar and they were like yeah sure why not
this movie's kind of like the game
kerplunk you have all these things
jammed into this cylinder holding up all
the marbles but you feel like if you
pull that one thing it's all gonna come
crashing down however still fun to play
that is interstellar in the end
interstellar is an ambitious movie it's
a good space drama I love the family
dynamic between McConaughey and his
family I love the relativity that they
show in this movie but I feel like
Christopher Nolan was overreaching in
what he had in mind for this movie
didn't quite I'll translate to scream
and it did not need to be damn near
three hours long to tell the story just
didn't regardless of its flaws it was
still an interesting movies I will say
interstellar is still a good time no
alcohol required and another reality of
the situation Nolan fans want it to be
the next 2001 a Space Odyssey 2001 a
Space Odyssey fans want it to be the
next 2001 Space Odyssey
it's just not all right so interstellar
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you